[Musique]
bonjour bonjour
maïté nous avons une fois de plus devant
nous une superbe natures mortes
quelle belle couleur quel beau produit
n'est ce pas c'est très joli cd des
fruits de saison et surtout qu'est-ce
que vous avez l'intention de nous faire
avec ça eh bien on va faire du boudin
aux châtaignes et aux pompes
ça c'est un plat très régional est très
fier las atteignent autrefois on disait
fait le pain du pauvre où l'on faisait
la castagnade aux corps d'une personne
fière de nous ce qu'est ce que c'est ça
ou castagnade et blanc se réunissaient
tous et on faisait cuire des châtaignes
et on buvait un majeur de sa taille du
ver nouveau oui et c'était et puis on
discute et on se rend compte d'une
histoire c'était merveilleux
si des merveilleux alors dont vous à
nous faire ce boudin ou chatagnier open
et si on a le temps fera peut-être une
seconde recette mais il faut le refaire
votre sort c'est une terrible asperges
au foie gras c'est le zéro c'est
sûrement très bon on mangera peut-être
pas les deux ou même repas si je vais
vous qu'est ce que l'art non pourquoi
pas ce genre après l'autre voir qu'est
ce qu'il vous faut comme produit pour
faire ses horizons faut bien entendu du
porto oui il nous faudra vendre 13
toujours en vain presse numérique
partout il faut des pommes
il faut des châtaignes nasale sont
encore dans leur niche hadary mois après
il faut de l'anis vous allez voir
pourquoi des fleurs d'un d'ici là il
nous faut voir les châtaignes corps
retrouvés ici il nous faut du bouddha
évidemment essayer du boudin spéciale à
voir sa série blood inquiet c'est aussi
avait des brûlures de certaines si vous
avez pris des feuilles et ça c'est qu'on
voit rarement voilà c'est pour des
feuilles de figues et or se sert pour
mettre dans l'eau pour cuire et
châtaignes alors là nice et l'as far cry
vie de figuig je vous assure que ça
donne un parfum extraordinaire c'est
délicieux un peu de sel et vous avez les
meilleurs amis du monde
et d'autant plus que la feuille de vives
de figues
vous venez de l'accueillir au jardin oui
beaucoup parlé alors et l'autre recette
et l'autre cette annonce et des asperges
et plus du foie gras et on va voir
comment on opère et par quoi est ce
qu'on va commencer
on va commencer par curé châtaignes on
va les grilles et anor pas cela cela je
vais laisser cuire à l'eau tout
simplement un pardon tout simplement
rempli
j'aimais de la bouillir oui dans cette
eau je vais mettre du sel
bien sûr comme plein jour du crb pas
tellement parce que vous allez voir est
une petite pincée de sucre à fouad aussi
un peu voilà du porto haut on améliore
toujours ordinaire stop ça c'est pas le
banc du pourvoi en amidon améliore un
petit peu deux feuilles deux filles
oui voilà et puis alors deux fleurs
danis ça va donner bon goût tout ça et
tout ça ça va faire parfumé et voilà et
on va mettre les châtaignes et on va les
faire cuire une heure et demie deux
heures à ces gens il faut dégoûté parce
qu'elle sommes pas très grosse au soleil
en a de beaucoup plus grosse et voilà et
pendant que sa cuisse on va s'occuper du
débit d'air et des pommes par quoi
commence ay vous par le boudin et qu'est
ce que vous en faites
voilà alors je lui pique un petit peu ou
pas qu'ils éclatent aurait été évité à
l'appareil
vous avez un atelier il faut savoir
votre équipe
là on va remettre trois rois bouder et
en même temps je vais y mettre
madame frêche qui va de cuir à manhattan
est toujours si jolie parce qu'elle
vient de vos amis d albi en arriver
voyez les quatre le bouder vous n'aurez
pas du tout pratique l'apd est ce que
c'est ça à en faire la hémoise je
m'occupais des pauvres
tenez vous de tourner entre l'intention
et parce qu'ils n'éclairent pas ton
volontaire de la poursuite en preview sa
feria mangera pareil de demande
demeurent doute
j'adore j'adore un peu quoi pm on
amènera autour des roues d'un abord ab
travail était bien là les gens qui n'a
pas éclaté
oui mais ce tarif social à l'ail et des
formes ça va être ça bat aujourd'hui oui
ça va bien je ne vous satisfaite
ce couple que ce n'est pas mal on savait
qu'ils allaient partir complètement la
doux non non non non non non non non non
non non non non non mais l'arcep a
feeling qui n'est pas encore dans l'air
c'est bon très bien à peu près ça
l'aurait des sportifs tout à une
assiette vols des trafics et je vais me
tenir tout ceci au chaud pendant le
bouder ça me paraît pas mal par m oui le
bout des doigts qui a éclaté mais ce qui
n'est pas en tenant dans sa main
d'oeuvre
mais ce qu'on voit apparaître étape
édition 1 ça donne déjà envie de goûter
voilà la stratégie c'est bon ça finira
depuis 1,9 à leur raccordement au cou
mais le garder au chaud au four oui
juste pour chauffer que sa queue de pie
voilà et là dedans je vais m'y mettre
mais peau noire qui vont prendre un bon
petit goût là voilà là et maintenant on
va les couvrir et on va les attendre ou
les laisser à découvert les arts parfois
parce que si on veut qu'elle dort il
faut qu'elle soit exactement
pendant ce temps on va s'occuper de
noces atteignent bien entendu qu'est ce
que vous leur avez c'est le roman garder
les plus jolies quand vous avez essayé
de ces feux les atteintes les trolls et
des sanctions faites pas l'air si vous
tournez s'il vous plaît et moi je vais
vous mettre un peu de bouillon
voilà là dedans
biennois pourtour et surtout pour faire
passer le tollé allez allez c'est bon
c'est bon on s'y fait si vous faites
avec sa gouaille et aux autres il a
gardé tout le jeu qui sort là c'est bon
c'est bien c'est bon médecine parfait up
et on s'en remet à me salir et ça vous
savez on fait pas de dégâts sur sa salle
est alors venu ceci dans ma cocotte
vous aviez c'est un petit peu sont un
petit peu chauffé et que je vais baisser
doucement
alors là dessus je prends je vais me on
avait mis au chaud
je mets ma femme fraîche orly de
ventrèche là sur ces châtaignes et ce
bouillon dire jolie le bout des rues le
prochain détaillé mais avec bon il a
tort voilà bien le jus taire ceux qui
négligent sera rien à prouver voilà vous
êtes pas mal regardé cette fraude aurait
l'air bien mais c'est encore un peu
fermes disent qu'elles vont recueillir
un dollar mais ça va réduire le temps
c'est bien voilà c'est joli et ses menus
et pas cher et pas cher et pas cher et
hr parce que les points c'est pas cher
le bouder ce n'est pas cher la ventrèche
c'est pas cher et c'est bon là ça y est
si vous n'êtes pas tout non non non non
non non alors le reste des châtaignes
voilà bien d'égaliser parfait et je vais
remettre un peu de bouillon dessus large
et pas couvrir mais il faut que ça te
lise quatre ans voilà il n'est pas
produire de loucher de louche je sais
que vous voyez vous même c'est suivant
la voile stop
ils savent à mijoter tout doucement
encore quoi cinq minutes à une demi
minute
ça nous laisse le temps de faire l'autre
recette latérite d'aspères geoffroy gras
est-ce difficile pas du tout la voilà on
a fait du bouillon qui se trouve là oui
mais c'est pas un bouillon comme
n'importe comment
c'est avec dépit de porte je latine
oui et là je vais me couper mon foie
gras vrai que je vais mettre un puis
tout doucement deux tranches me
suffisent mais je devais vous expliquer
après robin en fait la terrine la pana
que le x va cuivre parce qu'ils croient
qu'ils cuisent éternelle oui alors et le
poivre beaucoup d'efforts et oui voilà
alors d'içi gbe du bouillonne de la
gélatine
mais on a fait durcir dans l'infra
générateurs je vais mettre une couche
d'aspect rj oui voilà allez voir le foie
gras qui ne brûlent pas micheline oui
une couche d'asphalté comme ceux ci se
retourne je crois mais voilà il ne veut
surtout pas autre joli will et bien
voilà alors les asperges série la voilà
c'est pas difficile à faire je
reprendrai pas là et la guerre la
première est relative au lin et general
mills leader
oui mais j'aime bien que le foie goumois
ou modèle a rien derrière
alors je vais mettre le foin sur ce lit
d'affaires et de bouillottes on va le
mettre en travers pour que ça prenne un
petit peu mal joli ça mais bien sûr
voilà
et on arrive à mettre là dessus du but
idiot oui une autre couche de new york
il faut faire plusieurs étapes et attend
déposée de bien placer sa bouille ont
fait avec des pieds donc ça va prendre
en gelée danger et on va l'as rome
pourrait être générateur
pourquoi ça prenne pour que ça prenne
ainsi de suite ainsi du site et ainsi de
suite pendant ce temps d'autres bouderra
bien mijoté maïté mauges pas que c'est
parfait
moi c'est pour moi c'est prêt regardez
le bouder il est superbe les pommes
assure bien parce qu'elles ne sont pas
écrabouillé les faux pas il ne faut pas
les châtaignes
regardez les régions lee
oui la ventrèche et les dessous j'ai
goûté c'est délicieux il n'y a plus
besoin d'assaisonnement pour moi il faut
et m
surnom on a envie de les manger bien sûr
après c'est pas l'heure encore voilà non
pas encore eh bien il va falloir
entérine si elle l a pris il n'y a pas
de raison elle est magnifique
espérez vous aviez bien superposer des
quantités de couches là deux foies gras
et d'aspect rj c'est tout plein là je
les avais bien pris 2,2 alors maintenant
maintenant c'est le moment critique que
nous allons la démouler
avec l'espoir que l'on alexandre très
facile non normalement il faut la
laisser un jour deux jours wall au frigo
voir là il n'applique pas mr player le
bon dieu pour que tout aille bien
sous la serre voyais arriver tout seul
oh que oui 1 2 3 voilà j'ai entendu un
bruit les qui donne bon espoir et
regarder sa part fait j'ai l'air très
belle ça on sera mieux sur le non ça
c'est réussi et maintenant vous allez
couper une tranche je vais pour les deux
tranches pour voir de quoi c'est fait
de quoi elle est faite or elle est bien
prise un wiki superbe
c'est à dire c'est du dur à cuire de
sauver celle asperges qui est difficile
à couper de la retenir avaient les mains
je vous le dis aussi les voilà c'est bon
ça y est quoi la part fait jouer on
aurait pu mieux faire et comment dire
non mais on va courir là on voit très
bien le foie gras et où l'autre sens
pour l'accompagner bien sûr une petite
vinaigrette la salade au vinaigre de
noir
n'est ce pas là et regardez moi aleri de
nous à l'huile de noix pardon pardon
devient grenouille c'est vrai c'est
vraiment non plus élevé c'est parfait a
pas c'est parfait là est bien de très
jolis recettes très différents
fois et pour vous si vous avez envie
vous mangez en premier comme entrer la
terrine d'aspères et de foie gras en
gelée ensuite un solide bouder et samir
pas mal après lancez-vous une petite
sieste et bon appétit
à bientôt
[Musique]